The internet is a buzz about Sony's new Spider-Man
adjacent film "Madame Web," but maybe not
in the way the studio might hope.
Is it time for a new "Morbin' time?"
Sony's Spider-Man Universe—that still doesn't
have a Spider-Man—is developing a less-than-stellar
reputation for itself.
While superhero movie trailers usually command
attention and anticipation, that isn't happening
with its latest offering — the trailer for
"Madame Web," starring Dakota Johnson, Adam
Scott, and Sydney Sweeney.
The film isn't even out yet, and it's already
earning the collective ire of the internet
and may have already been memed more than
"Morbius."
People can have differing opinions, but the
collective consensus online seems to be that
"Madame Web" looks ... not great.
From poor dialogue to needlessly convoluted
exposition, "Madame Web" has plenty of people
loving to hate it on the world wide web.
Many on X, formerly known as Twitter, were
quick to point out how the costumes and acting
are reminiscent of what one might see on a
CW superhero show.
Others are already predicting very low box
office numbers, how low?
"Seven bucks!?"
One of the best things to come out of "Morbius,"
or maybe the only good thing depending on
who you ask, was the internet coining the
phrase, "It's morbin' time!"
Despite not being in the movie, it caught
on quickly and became a meme because it sounds
like the kind of cringey dialogue a movie
like "Morbius" would have.
"Madame Web" falls into that camp, and people
have no qualms over coming up with their own
fake dialogue for the film.
One can spot a trend in the YouTube comment
section of the "Madame Web" trailer.
People mention loving a part of the trailer
that isn't there.
For example, one commenter wrote,
"I love that part of the trailer when she
said 'It's webbing time' I cried [tears] of joy."
Others got a bit more obscure with their jokes,
with one user writing,
"I love the part when she says 'You know,
I'm something of a spidergirl myself' and
proceeded to web.
Truly a movie of all time."
This trend is repeated ad nauseam under the
video, but the common sentiment is clear:
No one really respects this movie.
Even BossLogic, who makes custom posters and
artwork for superhero movies and is usually
pretty complimentary, wrote on X,
"So looking forward to it but #MadameWeb should
have just released a teaser for now, till
they had a trailer that will blow us away."
But all the fake dialogue in the world couldn't
hold a candle to an actual line in the trailer
that's taken on a life of its own.
One major complaint against the "Madame Web"
trailer is that, at only three minutes long,
it gives away much of the plot, including
the antagonist's backstory.
At one point, Cassandra Web says,
"He was in the Amazon with my mom when she
was researching spiders right before she died."
With that line, the internet would never be
the same.
The clunky line delivered with all the passion
of a 4th grader delivering a book report for
a book they didn't read has inspired countless
memes and jokes.
One user posted a still from "The Room" featuring
Tommy Wiseau and imagined that his line reading
would be very similar to this famous scene,
"I did not hit her, it's not true.
It's bulls---.
I did not hit her.
I did not.
Oh, hi Mark."
They wrote,
"It's not true.
It's bulls---.
I did not go to the Amazon with your mom when
she was researching spiders just before she died.
I did naaaht.
Oh hi Madame Web."
What is it about this line that's captured
the internet's attention?
Is it how it crams in so much lore in a single
sentence?
Honestly, taking out the superfluous detail
of "she was researching spiders" would probably
help it flow more smoothly, but what's done
is done.
Who knows?
Maybe more people will check out "Madame Web"
when it comes out in theaters on February
14, 2024 to see what other meme-worthy gems
could be hiding in it.
Then again, people may just make up stuff,
and those who haven't seen the movie will
simply think it's true.